you know who's doing it right my friend  Diana who eloped in Hawaii I didn't even  realize she was engaged that out on  Facebook quite a shocker but I'm happy  for he seems nice then when they got  back two weeks later they threw a party  at their place with friends and family  super super casual I wore shorts they  were dressed shorts they didn't even  want any gifts that's okay cuz I brought  my famous casserole everyone loved it  aw so delicious John where'd you get  this so well I just threw it together I  found it on Pinterest but they don't  know that the event was luau aimed and  started at 4:00 and was over by 9:00 and  was an absolute blast  if this sounds very specific it is and  that's the point maybe some of you would  do good to follow their lead you know  who's doing it right those wine bars  with machines where you put in the card  buy tastings of various types of wine